hi everyone I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel today I'm doing another Q&A for
hitting 290 thousand and then 295
thousand subscribers I'm often bad at
getting these done on time but I did
want to get this one done before hitting
300 thousand because I have something
sort of special planned I'm basically
planning to give away a bunch of video
game codes and some game paths and all
of that kind of good stuff so um I just
wanted to celebrate mol for that one so
this one just a regular old Q&A that I
was supposed to film two weeks ago but
of course we begin by saying thank you
to everyone for subscribing I've had a
lot of fun making content this year
obviously there are ups and downs I
think I took a two-month break earlier
this year so to everyone who stuck
around with me in the periods of time
where I feel well enough or free enough
to make content thank you it's been fun
anyway I took questions on Instagram and
Facebook here they are uh Ben underscore
disco jamming on is gone it's go said
what's the most challenging aspect of
being a public figure
uh-huh and they're probably like a bunch
of things that would come to my head
depending on the day but I find it
difficult to watch people lie about me
and not say anything so people will just
make [ __ ] up just completely false and
then you will watch someone else on the
Internet
believe whatever they said I've had
people say they had a one-night stand
with me which is something I've
literally never done in my life and
everyone else will just believe them and
ask them how it was and then I'll give
details it is just a thing but I do find
it difficult that I know that I just
have to let that go if I have a see
something like that even if it's in my
own comment section I just have to
ignore it because it would take me way
too long to correct it all so probably
that people just completely making [ __ ]
up about you and other people just
blindly believing it kind of without
question and knowing that I cannot
intercept it I just have to let it
happen
psycho delray asked you a little spoon
or a big spoon I'm actually usually a
big spoon peeps of Magnolia said what
big aspirations do you have yourself
before turning 30 I would like to nap
less if I could be less tired that would
be great I spend it so much time
sleeping but really I want to buy a
house
or an apartment or I want to own some
kind of real estate by the time I'm 30
which I understand is going to be
extremely difficult but I've been saving
for that since I was 20 deaths plan
probably impossible banks current real
estate market cada SV said I know you
lost weight ages ago but how do you stay
in shape even with your health problems
or I guess how did you get in shape in
the first place so this year has been a
tough one because I have had a lot of
health problems and earlier in the year
particularly late last year actually it
was like November December and January
and a little bit of February I was told
to stop exercising as part of having a
chronic fatigue which is very uncommon
thing for a doctor to tell you to do but
it was making me faint
so I get why they told me to stop doing
it and that obviously means for a person
who was generally pretty active and goes
to the gym maybe five times a week
you're gonna gain weight but there was a
period of time during that where I
started doing yoga so I at least felt
like I was doing something active that
was also by suggestion of my doctor when
it comes to weight specifically because
usually when people stay say in shape
they're referring to how much you weigh
which I kind of disagree with that I
don't think those things should mean
that but that's usually what it means
it's all just calories you just have to
watch the amount of calories that you
intake every day that's it it is a very
specific science that will have results
next question is relevant tight in asked
ever worked out with any of the funhouse
boys I have yeah I've been to the gym
with James Adam warrants John Holland
and John Smith my sister asked why is
your sister so amazing she is a very
kind-hearted and loving person who cares
about the people who are close to her
very deeply and I think would defend
them to the death
there you go Sarah I you better have
watched this I swear to God the curse
st. I wonder why I'm getting so many
questions about this have you ever
considered quitting being a public
persona and if so what made you decide
to stick with it my field isn't one
where you are actually famous in any
capacity it's not an actor where people
are gonna find my stuff forever I could
just get rid of everything like it's not
really a continuous threat I could just
make new accounts and private everything
if I wanted
it's not actually permanent nificant
eros asked what do you enjoy about being
an on-screen personality that's a very
small amount of what I do I guess it's
really cool that I can just entirely be
myself and people will enjoy that and
sometimes celebrate it that's kind of
amazing
the Cavan ichael said if your youtube
channel becomes profitable enough will
you quit your job and do it full-time
no I really like working with teams I
like working on long-form projects and I
feel like unless you're huge on YouTube
that's not really possible it's also
just and I feel like I'm less you're
huge on YouTube that's not really
possible but it's also probably not the
kind of content I want to make not
full-time let loose the crack and said
what is your vote for the most
underrated game of the past year of 2019
so far I would say out of wilds everyone
who's played it rates it highly it's
just that not enough people have played
it and I also really like concrete genie
I think it has flaws so again perhaps
underrated it's not the right word but
it's really pretty and really peaceful
and I just feel like when people need to
play those games so if any human even
one of you watches this video and then
plays the outer wild and concrete genie
super kinky kinky Oh said does it bother
you when people fans are like ask you
about your personal life I relationship
status not at all
I actually find it really funny in my
lost Q&A someone asked if I was taken
and I said yes and then there are all
these conspiracy theories that I had
only said yes because people ask me if
I'm taken so much and I didn't very
strange it's like you're willing to
acknowledge that a lot of people ask me
if I'm taken but you can't comprehend
that I would be taking like I'm cool
enough to be asked if I'm single but I'm
not cool enough to actually be saying so
but generally no I think as long as
people aren't demanding I don't mind
what people ask me I don't think there's
anything that I get bothered by jewelry
frei he said how do you feel about
getting lots of unwanted affection do
you get lots of dm's and lots of people
trying to hit on
by social meeting if so how do you deal
with it and what would you like to say
to people that do and the people that
will again don't care do whatever you
want it's social media yeah you got to
expect some ridiculousness
well Jimmy twenty nine said what are
some things you have to deal with as a
female on youtube / online in general
that you feel like males don't have to
deal with again so many questions about
this kind of topic this time I wonder
why I mean people will tell me forever
that the only reason I've accomplished
anything is because I'm a woman or
because they think I'm attractive
despite the fact that I think I've
worked harder than honestly most men
that I know in my industry it's like
they just kind of walked in I had to
work my [ __ ] ass off because there
was so much scrutiny so many companies
being like are you really a gamer we
don't want to ruin our image by hiring a
game ago and I actually was told that
once so probably that I will just
constantly be told that I don't do
anything and I'm just a go which is just
so wildly untrue
Judy P said what is your favorite game
play you've done with fun house so far
my favorite has been son did the Sun
became plays is my number one pale bonus
what is your worst injury my wrists oh
they're bad I got tendinitis from
playing too many video games so yeah now
they don't really function as opposed to
fighting games heart I can't play guitar
hero for too long anything that requires
a lot of thumb movement will mess me up
sleepwalking 91 and said if you were
single could you see yourself dating a
younger guy and if so how much younger
would you date or older and how much
older which one would be I don't think I
would date someone younger than me I
can't even see myself dating someone my
own age I've never dated anyone he was
my age I've always been older and I'm
sure that'll change at some point like
maybe if I'm 30 people might start
feeling like children but right now a 26
year old I look at as a child I don't
know why I am one but I feel like it's
because all my friends like 30 to 40 at
this point although I don't know I feel
like I probably wouldn't date a 40 year
old kernel panic said is there a game
you're gret not being able to spend more
time with all of them so every single
one ah I like big breasts and I cannot
lie us what's your bus size
I'm glad you asked this is really the
only bus that I have in my apartment
it is a locust drone from kids wall came
out back in 2009
it's 19 inches tall and weighs about 14
pounds so it's up it's pretty big over
to Facebook
Joshua Velazquez's what's the
approximate cost your apartment
memorabilia my dude how dare you I don't
want to know you can't ask a lady that
question I don't even want to think
about it
well the Morgenson what's the proper way
to say assume look I say assume that is
how I say that I say H instead of H I
say assume instead of assume so assume
just sounds weird to me is that how you
say I don't like it it's just a regional
thing some people in Australia say
assume would rip said now that your
voice actor what does some of your
favorite voice actor performances in
games Troy Baker is incredible in the
loss of us and I think Laura Bailey in
he is v is exceptional there are plenty
of great game performances those are
just the two that stick out to me is
like really emotional and conflicted
roles that I think those two absolutely
nailed Brendon Hoffman said is your
current job your dream job I guess my
dream job was to work full time in games
mania and now I basically can which is a
weird thing to have hit so early I
basically achieved my life goals by 22
so now I'm just adding new goals but yes
I would say that what I do right now
probably is my dream job
Adam Castro's what you go to snackwell
gaming I don't snack pretty much not at
all I don't buy snacks that way I won't
eat snacks and I just try to eat regular
healthy meals even sometimes I'm bad at
that though but I do love a Mexican cook
I actually have a right now you just
wouldn't have seen me drinking it
because we edit that out but god I love
them they're not good for you I just
love the taste this was not sponsored by
cook but I wish bretburroughs asked in
what way does Finance allow you to do
what you want more than IGN I'm allowed
to livestream Brent I'm allowed to make
youtube videos about video games Brent I
wasn't even allowed to talk about movies
on my YouTube channel when I worked at
IGN they had a hard ban on all
that it was [ __ ] insane found it
especially nuts because I am a human who
they hired in part because I had a bunch
of YouTube subscribers they think I had
almost a hundred thousand by the time
that they hired me and then they stopped
letting me make the content that they
like in pot hired me for it was nuts I'm
allowed to voice acting video games IGN
probably wouldn't have that yeah it's I
can
I'm not restricted by being myself
anymore
but also you know I was in a few
episodes of Arizona Circle fun house has
animated shows roosterteeth has animated
shows movies and all that stuff it's
just a lot more content but I also get
to do the games media stuff with inside
gaming so every way maybe that said to
iTunes credit they have changed those
policies since I left someone you came
in and I know that they were like it
sucks that we did that and Alana wasn't
allowed to do this stuff and she left in
part because of that so in that offense
they have changed that stuff now but for
me it [ __ ] sucked
Nixon Coronado said do you still hit
Bruce laughing in your sleep because I
do I was with Bruce just last week last
Friday we went in did karaoke oh I hear
him in my sleep
not when I'm sleeping so much no call
and Carol said what's the best inning
game you've played most recently most
recently would probably be Abzu I was
playing that because I was sick the
other week and I kept coughing and I
couldn't get to sleep and it was very
relaxing beautiful game Derek Kolbert
asked any new love interest if so how
did you meet because sometimes I'm a SAP
uh I am seeing someone we met through
friends which is pretty much always
going to be my answer to that question I
think for the rest of my life I've
spoken about this on YouTube a bunch but
I don't do dating really Scott Dixon any
update on red lips orange car for those
who don't know that it's my podcast I've
recorded that ha I recorded two episodes
recording two more this week so it's
coming I don't know when yet because I
have to edit it all and it's a bit
different now but it is coming back
I am excited Christian Jesus Anna
Shanahan said if you don't with any more
chronic fatigue and I guess I'll leave
it on this question is the last one
yeah I've spoken about that a bunch in
this video and a bunch on the channel in
general yes this is an ongoing part of
my life chronic fatigue is something
that I will deal with currently
permanently to be classified with a
chronic illness it has to be long time
so it has to be more than six months for
the u.s. to recognize it so this isn't
something that is going to disappear
it's just better some weeks than others
I'm always tired I feel like every photo
I post every [ __ ] video and funhouse
people constantly say why does a lot of
look so tired she looks like she just
rolled out of bed yeah that's because of
a chronic illness that I have dog but
anyway I feel like I would answer that
because I am got the impression a lot of
people are curious about it so that's
the update it's permanent
all right everyone I'm Alanna thank you
for watching sorry I didn't upload for a
bit over a week like I said been real
busy and yeah do another Q&A at 300,000
it's very exciting I kind of can't
believe that thank you for watching
alright friends I will see you guys next
time